good evening folks we're here to present
the award the Best Adapted Screenplay
and not to get too technical but that's
the screenplay that was the best at
adapting to whatever harsh conditions
and obstacles were thrown in its way
no it's a screenplay adapted from
another source such as a novel play
short story or a TV show hmm
agree to disagree okay look it's I agree
that you're wrong look let's not fight I
mean my god we have to Quetta me Awards
between us this is beneath us
did you win a Moscow well now when you
put it like that but you have two
Academy Awards so technically there's
two between us okay can I have one no
you have to I have everyone well agree
to disagree okay can we go on and give
out this award so that more people can
have Oscars like we do listen but you
can't just go around saying here are the
nominees for Best Adapted Screenplay
Charles Randolph and Adam McKay for the
big short based on a book by Michael
Lewis Nick Hornby for Brooklyn based on
a novel by Colin tavini Phyllis Nagy for
Carole based on the novel the price of
salt by Patricia Highsmith Drew Goddard
for the Marshall based on the novel by
adding a Madonna who for rule based on
her novel and the Oscar goes to
Charles Randolph and Adam McKay the big
shot
this is the first Oscar nomination for
Charles Randolph and the first win for
Adam McKay who is also nominated for
directing the Big Short
Oh
thank you so much to the Academy also
thank you to Michael Lewis for writing
an amazing book it inspired Charles and
I so much taken a paramount for taking a
risk on a movie that's about financial
esoterica and believing in it thank you
to my beautiful wife sure Piven there
she is and my children Lily Rose my two
daughters Lily rose and pearl I love you
so much
most of all if you don't want big money
to control government don't vote for
candidates that take money from big
banks oil or weirdo billionaires stop
sorry thank you very much Plan B thank
you very much to Paramount to my wife
Miele inhabit our community to my kids I
am so happy to be your father